here uh Mission at MIT is to apply
knowledge gain through research
to solve the world's most pressing
problems
and we cannot do that without scientists
from historically marginalized
communities we want education to be
accessible
we want it to be free we want it to be
open and we wanted to reflect the
communities in which people serve people
learn and people teach we are now in a
climate where people are trying to limit
when you learn how you learn and what
you learn I'm here to promote oer open
education resources and open education
means exactly that it's open oh yeah
means to me that it is possible for
somebody who looks like me came from the
same world as I did
to achieve something that they never
dreamed of it's accessibility it's
Freedom it's
a gift it means it means the world to me
and that's why I'm so excited I'm like
this is possible this is finally
possible you have three powerful forces
coming together again the hbcus MIT
Merlot the need is worldwide for people
of all racist underrepresentative
populations to be able to access
information and to tap in to Rich
cultural resources to help them in their
academic Journey there is no one size
fits-all in education we have very
different and unique experiences in
terms of our histories our culture our
education our disciplines but we're
finding ways to connect the values and
goals that we have that will benefit not
only the students at our institution but
institutions faculty
[Music]
and students around the world